- In news, that should
surprise no one news,
Rudy Giuliani is apparently
having a hard time
getting President Trump to
pay for his legal services.
Rudy Giuliani made
headlines earlier this year
by apparently seeking
up to $20,000 per day
to represent the President.
Of course, President Trump has a history
of stiffing his creditors.
Now the interesting thing
here is that lawyers
aren't really allowed to just
stop representing a client.
If they're in active litigation,
the court will often
see if it's a good time
if it would prejudice the
client for the attorney
to just leave in the middle of precedings.
But then again, the lawyer doesn't have
to take on additional representation,
which might actually explain why Rudy
has refused to represent the President
at his upcoming impeachment trial.
Lawyers are just the
worst until you need one.
So stay tuned for more legal analysis,
and as always, I'll see you in court.